So, now let's look at the brain and what happens when we're engaging in short
term or working memory. Here we see that the prefrontal cortex focuses
attention on a sensory stimuli, and will hold the information long enough for
us to solve the problem at hand. Then it will transfer the information to the
hippocampus for memory consolidation. We also know that the encoding stage of
memory is consolidated through rehearsal and repetition. So, if we repeatedly
fire the neural impulses that are necessary to convert a short term memory to a
long term memory, this will occur in the hippocampus. Now, the main reason
Henry Molaison or HM, could no longer form long term memories is because a
large part of his hippocampus was removed. But as I said, we know that the
hippocampus isn't the only thing that's important for working memory. We also
need our prefrontal cortex, which is responsible for our ability to maintain
attention and focus. So, when you're reading, having a conversation or looking
at a map. When trying to figure out directions, it's our prefrontal cortex that
allows us to keep this information available. Do you remember earlier in the
lesson when we discussed the visuospatial sketchpad in phonological loop? Well,
we see that in each of these areas is where brain activity occurs during each
of these processes. So, we know that auditory input is processed and rehearsed
in the phonological loop from the prefrontal cortex. To the language
comprehension center, which is located to the back and left part of the
parietal lobes. We call this language comprehension center, the Wernicke's
region, after the person who discovered it. You may remember this when we
talked about it in lesson three. As for visual information in the visuo spatial
sketchpad, it goes from the prefrontal cortex to the temporal lobes for spatial
information. And then to the occipital lobe for visual information. Now, we
know that our explicit memory storage are stored in the respective cortex in
the area that it was originally processed. Now, other types of memories such as
implicit memories are stored in structures of the subcortex, specifically the
striatum, amygdala and cerebellum.